westmount lieu de tradition et de
vieilles habitudes ici la coutume veut
qu'à chaque élection
une forte majorité d'électeurs votent
pour le parti libéral
c'est difficile de faire changer d'année
gamme d'allégeance un homme qui vit dans
confort mais avec les modifications à la
carte électorale le comté change
il s'étend maintenant vers notre dame de
grâce jusqu'à montréal ouest serait pas
ce chômeur compte bien voter pour le
candidat néo démocrate ni paix le
libéral marc garneau ne prend donc rien
à la légère surtout qu'en 2011 il l'a
remportée par une très mince avance à
peine plus de 600 voix je suis
certainement conscient du fait que j'ai
un adversaire de taille dans le npd n'a
cette fois ci et pour cette raison là je
fais du porte à porte depuis l'automne
dernier adversaire néo-démocrate c'est
lui j'ai news l'ancien directeur de la
mission aubry prédit lui aussi une
course très serrée
ça risque d'être super intéressant le le
19 octobre
cet homme donnera son appui aux
conservateurs je considère que c'est le
seul qui a tenu qui s'est tenu
convenablement dans la sphère des
migrants mais il croit que la course ici
sera quand même entre les libéraux et
les néo-démocrates
il ya des possibilités que le mpd gagne
parce que le monsieur qui se présente
comme bonhomme collecte la partie qui
représente l'islam et l'autre face je
vais voter pour vous c'est quel parti ça
je pense que les barrages
si ici le rouge domine depuis des
décennies plus difficile cette fois
d'annoncer à l'avance la couleur du
vainqueur